Nikki what do you mean she's gone baby
we ought to be home with your family she
all right she's fine
my baby I've been telling them for years
you got to figure out what you want to
do with mom when the time comes because
we all know why this thing works
I'm sorry out of here more often you got
family had girls you got a husband
you're here plenty she was trying to go
home
she thinks she's still a little girl or
she can't figure out why she's stuck
here
who's that all what is there no that is
he's my boyfriend
see you got any idea what I got going on
here I get to pick up mom pops
dry-cleaning taking the church
grandma drink the holy water know this
you side right and I'm not putting your
mother in a nursing home
you know everyone thinks being alone is
so bad tables a little late looking over
at the man that you've been married to
for the last 20 years and thinking he
must be feeling the same way I am love
is commitment I don't have what you have
oh no that's the other honor his name's
Nick two horses me
I got my life savings dumped it in this
place you're a bartender bar owner dad
[Music]
you know I'm gonna have a baby did you
know this dad I heard you saved all your
old baby clothes just gonna forget
everything the better or worse citrus
and now that do you part that is the
promise she's my girl you can't take my
girl away from me
what happened acquitting wife Betty wife
happened in the wedding
[Music]
you